sur une échelle gay de un à dix, je suis une [ __ ] de Judy
Garland 42
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je ne viens pas de très loin, j'ai dû
lutter et me battre pour devenir la femme
que je suis aujourd'hui
[Musique]
quand j'étais  plus jeune, j'étais tellement en insécurité et
j'ai été victime d'intimidation à l'école et je ne
croyais pas en moi, mais quand j'ai eu 19 ans, j'ai
décidé que je voulais devenir musicien
et je me suis lancé en courant et je
martelais le trottoir à New York en
frappant  à chaque porte pour trouver un emploi pour
chanter partout où je peux
[Musique]
Je suis un militant des droits des homosexuels et un
militant pour la justice sociale Je crois au pouvoir
de la musique pour changer la vie des gens
malgré les avancées politiques réalisées en
termes de droits et de visibilité  en tant que
personne LGBT, malheureusement, la vérité et le fait
est que l'homophobie, la violence
et l'intimidation anti-gay sont vivantes et réelles.
[Musique] [
Musique]
Je ne peux m'empêcher de penser que ce niveau de
haine, comme tous les crimes préjudiciables,
est une attaque  sur l'humanité elle-même
[Musique]
seules les déclarations que je ferai à
la mi-temps sont celles
que j'ai toujours faites
tout au long de ma carrière. Je crois en une
passion pour l'inclusion. Je crois en l'
esprit d'égalité.
[Musique]
toi